au panier de la ferme parmi les petites
mains qui s'affairent pour s'occuper des
commandes on trouve les bénévoles de la
protection civile des yvelines nouvelle
mission pour ces volontaires préparation
de cageots et de paniers pour les
clients mais sans contact physique
nous avons déjà des bénévoles qui
commandait par internet au ca auprès de
cette ferme est donc suite à cette crise
ou bien dans la discussion dans la
communication n'a su qu'ils seraient
énormément difficulté puisqu'ils ont par
rapport aux chiffres quotidiens qu'ils
ont habituellement ils ont plus de 400
personnes qui commandent actuellement
par internet
donc ils se sont complètement senti
débordé donc qu'ils ont demandé si avec
nos missions s'il était possible qu'on
vienne les renforcer des renforts
précieux pour les paniers de la ferme
le gérant a organisé des espaces pour
accueillir tous les bénévoles en évitant
un maximum les contacts ça va bien
soulagé surtout dans le sens où bon déjà
nous on voulait pas parce que j'ai eu
des demandes aussi bénévoles etc
le problème c'est qu'en ce moment on
essaie quand même même si on reçoit
beaucoup de public
on essaie de se confiner de se protéger
nous aussi donc on a une équipe
nous on va dire confiné même si j'ai des
salariés mais on est confiné entre vous
et après l'après midi j'ai mais plutôt
justement c'est comme j'ai davantage
aussi d'avoir plusieurs bâtiments ils
sont dans un bâtiment de leur côté et
nous on est de notre côté et ça permet
d'éviter aussi trop les contacter
isabelle est venu prêter main forte à la
ferme pour la préparation des commandes
mais aussi pour les livraisons de
paniers aux personnes âgées
elle fait elle aussi partie de la
protection civile des yvelines
j'ai été malade j'ai protégé ma famille
je ne souhaite pas d'eau feront
directement du covic 19 donc ça me
permet de faire une mission utile mais
on protéger quoi la plupart des
commandes sont à récupérer à des
horaires précis du mercredi au samedi à
la ferme de la muette à ecquevilly les
autres colis seront livrés à domicile
pour les personnes à risque